So let's start with a warm-up activity to create
concepts for more, and less. We'll actually use these later
as they're central to the conceptual model of the
Time Bank. With the Time Bank, when we do tasks
for someone, we get more time in our account.
And after someone does a task for us, when we
pay them, we get less time in our account. So
let's follow along with the students. So we're going to do
a very quick exercise. Get a new big piece of paper. Some of the things you need
to communicate in your wallet are conceptual models of more or less.
All right, so we're going to take a few minutes and you're going to do ten
conceptual models of how you can show, how you can depict more or less/